lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
intentar implementar el algoritmo de
ordenamiento por inserción del que
hablamos en el vídeo anterior y lo haré
como una función de payton así que
llamaré esta función ordenamiento por
inserción y tomara una lista trabajará
sobre una lista lista es el parámetro de
la función así que tendremos que pasarle
una lista como argumento y lo que
haremos será pasar por cada lugar o
espacio de la lista creo que puedo
llamarla de esa manera cada espacio de
la lista entonces definiremos por índice
en range podríamos empezar en el espacio
de la lista que está hasta la izquierda
así que podemos escribir leen leen es
una forma corta del ent longitud de la
lista lo que estamos haciendo aquí es
obtener la longitud de la lista que
pasamos como argumento vamos a suponer
que la lista tiene cuatro elementos
entonces ley de lista es igual a cuatro
va a ser evaluado como cuatro y range de
cuatro va a producir una lista que tiene
cuatro
elementos 0 1 2 3 entonces índice va a
poder pasar por cada uno de los
elementos de la lista que queremos
ordenar y podemos hacerlo de esta manera
pero recuerden del vídeo anterior cuando
estamos haciendo un ordenamiento por
inserción no tiene sentido empezar con
el elemento 0 de la lista el elemento
que está más a la izquierda de la lista
porque no hay ningún elemento con que
comparar así que empezamos con el primer
elemento el elemento que está más a la
izquierda es el elemento 0 y el elemento
que sigue es el elemento 1 así que voy a
poner aquí 1 entonces vemos ahora que si
la lista tiene cuatro elementos esta
función range así como la escribimos va
a generar una lista con los elementos 1
2 y 3 iniciamos con el 1 luego el
siguiente a la derecha es 2 y el último
es 3 recuerden que una lista siempre
empieza con el elemento 0 y el término 0
es el que está a la izquierda de la
lista
ok ahora podremos recorrer nuestra lista
y en este momento podemos obtener el
valor del elemento de nuestro índice
entonces decimos valor es igual a lista
índice lista índice esto no significa
que va a ser la implementación más
eficiente del ordenamiento por inserción
esto va a ser mi mejor intento
escribiendo en tiempo real en una manera
que espero realmente espero que puedan
entender así que valor tiene ahora el
elemento de la lista que vamos a
comparar con todo lo que está a la
izquierda y lo que quiero hacer es
comparar valor con cada uno de los
elementos que están a la izquierda
entonces déjenme definir la variable y
que será el índice del elemento con el
que quiero comparar el valor en turno lo
que tengo en la variable valor lo quiero
comparar con lo que tengo a la izquierda
así que hice era igual a índice menos 1
y ahora tiene el valor del índice que
está justo a la izquierda del elemento
que queremos comparar y voy a seguir
modificando el valor de i para que sea
menor cada vez y pueda comparar con cada
elemento que está a la izquierda
entonces lo que queremos hacer es seguir
comparando con cada cosa a la izquierda
hasta que y tenga el valor del principio
de la lista y la variable y va a tener
el valor del índice que está hasta la
izquierda o del inicio de la lista
cuando valga 0 cuando i sea igual a 0
queremos entonces entrar en este ciclo
while mientras si sea mayor o igual a 0
porque si continuamos asignando valores
menores cada vez a la variable y para ir
cada vez más a la izquierda de la lista
no queremos llegar a un valor tan lejano
que sea negativo esto empezaría a hacer
tonterías así que mientras si sea mayor
o igual que 0
voy a seguir disminuyendo el valor de y
cada vez para ir a la izquierda tratemos
de esta manera y lo primero que voy a
hacer después de estar un espacio de la
izquierda
a comparar si valor es menor que el
elemento que tiene el índice y así que
el elemento que tiene el índice y es
lista y el elemento que tiene el índice
y es este de aquí entonces si valor es
menor que este elemento lo que tenemos
que hacer es cambiar este elemento a la
derecha entonces el espacio al que
debemos cambiar valores lista y + 1
lista y + 1 y yo podría decir que es
simplemente índice porque recuerden voy
a estar cambiando y para que disminuya
cada vez y en este momento y ese índice
menos 1 porque es la primera pasada del
ciclo while pero como verán en un
momento voy a continuar disminuyendo el
valor de y así que no siempre será un
lugar a la izquierda de índice solamente
en esta primera pasada del ciclo while y
decimos no importa lo que valga ahí voy
a ponerme un lugar a la derecha así que
el elemento de la lista que está en el
índice que corresponda a 1 lo voy a
reemplazar con lo que está
en lista y voy a tomar lo que está en
lista y cualquier cosa que tenga ese
elemento de la lista y lo voy a poner en
el espacio que está a la derecha un
espacio a la derecha y luego vamos a ir
paso a paso por esto y veremos la manera
en que se cambian los elementos y luego
podemos cambiar valor a la izquierda así
que cualquier cosa que esté en este
espacio de aquí va a ser reemplazado por
valor entonces lista ahí va a ser igual
a valor ok
déjenme escribir un comentario aquí
cambia el número del espacio y al
espacio
de la derecha
+ 1 y aquí voy a escribir otro
comentario cambia valor al espacio
si recuerdan lo que hicimos en el vídeo
anterior es exactamente esto
comparábamos un valor con lo que estaba
a la izquierda y si era menor entonces
tomábamos el número que estaba en la
caja de la izquierda y lo cambiáramos a
la derecha y cambiamos el número que
estábamos comparando a la izquierda y
ahora vamos a comparar valor con el
elemento que sigue a la izquierda así
que tenemos que disminuir y hacemos si
igual hay menos 1 y vamos a entrar al
ciclo while otra vez y ahora comparamos
valor con lo que está dos espacios a la
izquierda del índice original lo
comparamos con eso y si es menor cambia
el valor a la derecha y también cambia
valor otra vez a la izquierda y ahora
qué pasa si tenemos la situación en la
que valor no es menor que el elemento de
la lista con el que estamos comparando
bueno si valor no es menor que el
elemento con el que estamos comparando
eso significa que el valor está en el
lugar correcto que el valor ya no será
menor que los elementos que están a la
izquierda y que hemos terminado las
comparaciones no es necesario seguir
comparando hacia la izquierda
entonces hemos terminado y escribimos
break y creo que esto puede funcionar a
menos que haya cometido algún pequeño
error así que veamos si esto funciona
como un algoritmo de ordenamiento
déjenme salvarlo ordenamiento por
inserción y déjenme correrlo ok qué
bueno que no tuve ningún error de
sintaxis sintaxis significa que están
bien utilizados los caracteres que no
olviden poner dos puntos aquí aunque el
signo mayor está bien o sea que payton
puede interpretar todo lo que está aquí
escrito pero veamos si realmente
funciona voy a definir una lista y
déjenme definir una lista
digamos 7 1 359 2 y 3 esta es la lista y
déjenme ver este es el momento de la
verdad ordenamiento por inserción
a ordenamiento por inserción de a vamos
a ver qué pasa
recuerden estamos ordenando esta lista
en su lugar esta función no devuelve
nada pero debe haber tomado los
elementos de esta lista y los debe haber
cambiado para que ahora estén ordenados
y este es el momento de la verdad vamos
a ver cómo se vea y escribimos print
ok está ordenada bueno creo que no
cometí ningún error y aquí tienen una
versión de ordenamiento por inserción